[Music]
gruffly you've arrived at after the God
path go after seems to be the word of
this year we're after everything the
discovery of the Higgs boson dubbed at
the time as the god particle was
celebrated worldwide back then as an
explanation for mass itself it seemed
like we actually explained something
really fundamental no we did I knew we
shouldn't have invited illness but all
is not well John there is now talk at
CERN of what some people are calling the
nightmare scenario because simply
because they haven't been that many new
discoveries that might enable them to
make an elegant theory to make sense of
a current chaos a chaos of lots and lots
of particles and innumerable an infinite
number of universes which the theories
say they need so this has led some
people to wonder well should we just
abandon supersymmetry and string theory
and all of the other attempts to provide
the much promised theory of everything
or so was the Higgs a step towards this
this alleged theory of everything or is
the theory behind it and in fact
particle physics itself were in real
trouble so to help us wade our way
through that we have on my right
Catherine Haman's Catherine is the
professor of astrophysics of European
Research Council fellow at the
University of Edinburgh
you're basically Institute of astronomy
mm-hmm an astronomer thank goodness
thank God we got an astronomer sees the
first winner of the new Max Planck
Humboldt award for her research into
dark energy as perhaps in this best
known for her techniques of trying to
extract the information about the nature
of the universe from our actual
observations to my left Ben Allen ak as
a professor at the Department of Applied
Mathematics and theoretical physics at
Cambridge University and also I'd just
like to get this one record something of
a wild man if you agree to go out
clubbing with him
and whatever you may have read as a
local press it was his fault and I have
witnesses and then we have our resident
troublemaker John Ellis
Maxwell prize-winning theoretical
physicist who since 1978 has been the
man keeping CERN running because it's
the only person who understand how it
works he's made important contributions
in many fields of inquiry including
particle physics astrophysics cosmology
and writes very good pantomimes why has
it gone quiet
but CERN am i kicking off yeah exciting
so I'm slightly different from our two
other panel members here in that I'm an
astrophysicist and that means I question
the universe on much larger distances
time and mass scales than my to particle
physics colleagues here
I'm also an experimentalist so I go out
and I observe the universe and I extract
as much information as I possibly can to
confront the different theories that my
theoretical colleagues here on my left
come up with and now my specialist area
is called dark matter now if you are
happy to believe that Einstein's theory
of general relativity fully describes
gravity then there has to be invisible
matter out there in the universe and
indeed in this very room now I can tell
you where that dark matter is I can tell
you how much dark matter there is
there's roughly about five times as much
dark matter as there is the stuff that
we made up of I can tell you that the
dark matter can only act very very
weakly with the stuff that we made up of
might not even interact at all but I
can't tell you what the dark matter
particle is and for two decades now I
have been waiting for our particle
physics cousins to either catch one of
these elusive dark matter particles in
these deep underground rats and very
heavy elements um or create one of these
particles at the Large Hadron Collider
at CERN I am still waiting now whilst
I've been waiting I've also been
watching and there's been some amazing
technological advances it is absolutely
phenomenal what they can do at CERN now
they are recreating the conditions or
some of the conditions that it was like
around the Big Bang it is phenomenal
what they're doing but that experiment
was benchmarked on a theory that we're
going to be discussing today
supersymmetry
that predicted that not only would CERN
discover the Higgs boson but it would
also discover these supersymmetric
particles which john was one of the
first people to predict would be an
excellent candidate for the dark matter
that I seek and so of course it's very
disappointing that CERN hasn't found
these particles yet and but I take issue
with the question why has it gone quiet
at CERN because that would suggest that
they haven't been doing anything that's
simply not true there's been huge
amounts of advances since that discovery
of the Higgs boson in trying to really
understand the science behind the Higgs
boson and from that we might learn more
about this overarching theory that we're
going to discuss where Thursday I'd like
to say the question was just based on an
old football chant okay it's all gone
quite over there and why has it gone
quite right yeah well sends a very noisy
place as you know so now I've spent my
whole career working on supersymmetry
until last year and the fact that
supersymmetric particles haven't been
found at CERN has made me re-evaluate
the supersymmetry theory and I for now
I'm not working on it I'm working on
other things I'm looking for glitches in
the data and trying to work in a more
bottom-up way from the data in a
theoretical direction rather than what I
used to do which was work on some of
these units unified theories which used
supersymmetry is a bridge to get to low
energies it's the problem with that way
that means I'm well okay so the the
reason that we thought that the Large
Hadron Collider should be able to
produce supersymmetric particles is
because supersymmetry explains why the
Higgs boson isn't really heavy okay so
the Higgs boson is a very particular
article it's sensitive to mass it
explains how elementary particles get
their mass but it's very sensitive to
quantum fluctuations you know the vacuum
isn't really empty space it's a seething
boiling mass of particles and Higgs
boson is very sensitive it's
particularly sensitive to those and if
you do a back-of-the-envelope
calculation you see that it's mass
should be about billion billion times
the mass of a proton and it's only 100
times the mass of a proton so this is a
puzzle and we don't understand the
answer and supersymmetry was the was the
answer and is this why you're now so
that's why I was so signed up that's
that I was so infused of it about it
that I thought well let's try and help
see how we could discover it but then it
wasn't you know we know that to some
degree that it's not that it's not light
enough it doesn't solve this problem
very well at least so I so for me now
the way that I can make progress more is
to work in the other way and looking
elsewhere at the data to you know for
example that these particles called
bottom mesons they seem to be decaying
with the wrong frequencies comparing to
the compared to the standard model of
particle physics for me that's an
opportunity so we've invented a new
quantum force theoretically that could
describe why these bottom maisons are
decaying in this weird way and then
we're trying to look for other signature
signals of our you've actually in
proposed a new force of the universe
have you mentioned this to anyone we
published a few papers okay we're not
the only ones I must say there are
competing theories but one of the things
we do is to try and suggest ways that
you can save the data and new
measurements that you can make in order
to be able to tell which theory is
correct but suggesting a new force
that's quite a big thing isn't it it is
a bold step it's a bold step but
actually it's one that many of us have
taken it's become more common
recently it's you know it's really all
you have to do is invent a new yuan
gauge Theory multiplied by the standard
model and spontaneously break it and no
problem you so many of you have but John
okay John go on so had I take it it
hasn't actually gone quieter so and well
do you take some of the because Ben
sounds like a boy he was promised
something for Christmas and they didn't
get it yeah well I'm sorry about that
Ben no maybe next Christmas yeah so it
hasn't so let's step all the way back
how does science progress so so science
does not progress you know at a constant
rate it sort of goes along fairly slowly
for a while and then if there's some big
discovery or some great new insight and
it makes a jump and you know as kun said
you've got a new paradigm right there
and so no there's periods of sort of
accumulative data taking and then you've
got periods where there's no something
suddenly changes very rapidly and so for
me the Higgs boson was was just such a
rapid change you know we had been you
know for almost 50 years trying to
figure out where the hell particle
masses came from you know Peter Higgs
had this crazy idea and leastly seemed
crazy initially then as time went on
people crossed off all the other ideas
and you know Higgs was pretty much the
only guy left standing and yeah it was
it was the higgs boson
so so that gave us a great leap forward
in our understanding of the nature work
way nature works but but then you know
of course then you know things move more
slowly what we're currently doing is you
know a little bit like what Katherine
and then described we're studying in
great detail the properties of the Higgs
boson to see whether it really is well
the Higgs boson or some imposter we're
looking to see whether you know maybe
it's not quite behaving in the same way
that the standard model describes or
whether it's behaving in a way described
for example by supersymmetry but but
maybe I somebody should say what
supersymmetry is right can you do it
easily do you want to know what
supersymmetry yeah John the floor is
yours
okay so the with the way that
theoretical physics works
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit a I dot TV
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas